MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Hi.
I'm Maya Kaczorowski.
And I'm here at KubeCon
EU walking the floor.
And I'm here with
Kamil from GitLab.
Kamil, how are you doing today?
KAMIL TRZCINSKI:
Oh, I'm quite busy.
Actually we-- first,
we actually are
talking with a lot of people.
They are very interested in
our Kubernetes integration
that we started offering.
And there is also a
lot of work and a lot
of very nice ideas
about the feature
that we plan to introduce.
So basically, we are
able to meet with people
to discuss our plans and
what they actually each are.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So tell
me a bit more about GitLab.
What are some of the things
that GitLab currently does?
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: We
actually spent a lot of time
on trying to be
the best on devops.
We introduced Auto
DevOps, which kind of
follows the strength of
being very good integrated,
integrated with the
Kubernetes basically,
simplifying interaction
with the Kubernetes.
Because Kubernetes by
itself, it's a great product.
But it's also quite complex
to people starting using that.
We have this kube-apiserver.
We have this
deployment manifest.
And then we have the Helm.
These are not easy
things to teach.
Their learning
curve is quite high.
But with Auto DevOps
we simplify all of that
into a set of conventions
and our implementation
of these conventions.
So you can start
right like that.
You just push your
application to GitLab.
We test your application.
We perform security scanning.
We create a container in
each of your applications
and post a container registry,
then provide your staging
and production environments.
And actually when you even go
to our Kubernetes integration,
you just click a button, log
into Google, to your Google
Cloud, and maybe attach
your credit card,
and in five minutes you have
working Kubernetes cluster
and your working
application, maybe
the application that
is based on the beatbox
that our hierarchy is providing.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So I can
deploy directly from GitLab
to Kubernetes engine?
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: Exactly. right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
That's amazing.
KAMIL TRZCINSKI:
It's like-- it's
even more like
directly from GitLab
using Google Cloud
to Kubernetes engine.
So we try to remove
all the barriers
on deploying your application.
You just care about
your application.
You don't care about
the infrastructure.
the containers.
You care about the application.
You care about the workflow.
You care about the
practices, something
that I know that
this is probably
one of the most requested
questions that we have now.
What is the best practice
to work with the Kubernetes?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Right.
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: There
is so much technology
right now in the market.
And so many different ideas
that people are basically lost.
And we try to solve that need.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Try help
people out, help developers.
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: Yes.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: That's great.
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: Thank you.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
And anything else you
want to talk about here,
while we're here at KubeCon?
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: We have
very big plans for the CI
integration on GitLab.
There are a lot of
things happening.
For example, I spent time
with our contributors,
right before this conversation,
about the next upcoming feature
for the CI, which is like
ability to debug jobs live,
using the web
terminal, something
that is becoming a
fundament to Web IDE
that we are right now
working on that got
introduced, I think
in 10.7 or it's
going to be introduced in 10.8.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: OK.
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: And Web
IDE is actually quite cool.
Because--
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
What does it do?
KAMIL TRZCINSKI:
Consider that you start--
usually we have this tendency,
like we open our terminal.
We our open our VSCode or some
other IDE on our computers.
And we start writing.
We commit, push, maybe
we run some tests.
But let's say that
you don't need that.
Let's say that you have
your computer, which
is a terminal, like a terminal
to the world, to the Cloud.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Right, you
just want to use that directly
for a computer.
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: And you
just open the browser.
We just provision
you everything.
We just give you
the source code.
We provision you an
environment workspace
where you can work
on much beefier
machines than your
lightweight MacBook, right?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Yes, understood.
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: So It makes--
it's actually way
easier, faster,
because it's much easier to
switch between different work
spaces, so between
different tasks,
and remove you from trying to do
all these heavy-duty operations
on your computer, which
are [INAUDIBLE] kind
of under-powered.
Like GitHub itself, we
are running 27,000 tests
every commit.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Wow, that's a lot.
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: So
it's crazy when you
will try to run that locally.
So we basically try
to use that power up
of the GitHub, and
GitHub CI, and Web IDE,
and the terminal integration
to move everything
into Cloud, where you can have
basically unlimited resources.
And if you consider that you
can use that with the Kubernetes
and Google Cloud,
something that we offer,
it makes it basically an
infinite scalable solution
that you are never
limited by anything.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Thank
you so much, Kamil.
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: Thank you.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: I hope
you're having a good KubeCon
right now.
KAMIL TRZCINSKI: It's amazing.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Good.
And to all those
watching, I hope
you're enjoying watching
these videos of us at KubeCon.
We'll see you in Seattle.
[MUSIC PLAYING]